the number of homeless here in the
valley continues to grow it is a
concerning problem with many facets to
understand namely how to really help
Clark County Commissioners will be
tackling the issue with their next
meeting in our Lauren negretti joining
us live in studio to break it down good
morning Lauren good morning Heather
that's right nearly 15 million dollars
in Grants now the money will help
programs including Rapid re-housing
permanent Supportive Housing case
management and other Supportive Services
the funds will go to the Southern Nevada
homelessness Continuum of Care to help
address homelessness over the next three
years the Commissioners will recognize
the historic Grant at their meeting
tomorrow morning
the money comes from the U.S Department
of Housing and Urban Development live in
The Newsroom Laura negretti 8 news now
Lauren thank you it is 605